the left is crying crocodile tears over
fake incitements to violence meanwhile
leftists repeatedly commit actual
violence against conservatives including
little ol me during a campus lecture
last Thursday we will expose the left
sham grievance games from Ilan Omar to
Nancy Pelosi I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
you never really want to be the story I
guess it makes show preparation a little
bit easier but we will talk about this
because it fits into a broader story on
left-wing violence and incitement to
violence because when I was giving a
speech at the University of Missouri
Kansas City last week some leftist wacko
tried to attack me
we'll get to that in a second but first
you ever buy something online only to
find out later you missed a discount
I don't overspend anymore thanks to
honey honey is a free browser add-on
that finds me the best deals online I
have been using honey since long before
the daily wire existed I have been
telling people to get it it has saved me
like thousands of dollars it magically
Auto applies the best deal to my car to
check out honey finds discounts and
coupons across 37,000 sites with honey I
don't worry about missing a deal I just
shop like normal honey handles the rest
I use it truly for everything I buy the
last thing I bought was watch straps I
wanted new watch straps so I I just
anything I mean even something as
trivial as that honey we'll find you the
best deals on but I've been using it for
years I've been using it for everything
it'd be it'd be easier to point out what
I haven't used honey - bye honey members
have already saved more than 800 million
bucks it's not bad for something that is
completely free it takes just two clicks
to install honey has over a hundred
thousand five-star reviews on the google
chrome store there is no reason not to
use honey it is free money is it is free
to use it's free to install on your
computer in just two clicks shop with
confidence get honey for free at join
honeycomb slash cough fa c OV e fe fe
that's join honey calm slash cough fa c
OV e fe fe honey the smart shopping
assistant that saves you time and money
when you're shopping online we'll get to
left-wing violence in a second and a
history of violence but I guess on the
same topic we're getting breaking news
now the cathedral Notre Dom is on fire
and it's not just a little fire it is a
fire that is engulfing the whole thing
we don't yet have word as to whether
this was caused by a terrorist attack or
whether it was just an accident
I know they're doing renovation on the
Cathedral it looks as though one of the
West's most important landmarks one of
the most important works of art in the
history of Western civilization is
currently being destroyed it is burning
to the ground I just looked up on the
Wikipedia page for Notre Dom the
Wikipedia page now says notre dom
cathedral was a medieval Catholic
cathedral on the Ile de la Cite a in
Paris was this is just in the last few
minutes that's being reported we will
update you as news comes in it's being
reported now as probably an accident the
only reason that terrorism seems
possible one is because there have been
a lot of other terrorist attacks in
Europe and especially in France on
important places also because today is
the first day of Holy Week
today's the Monday of Holy Week Holy
Week leads into the passion Good Friday
and Easter Sunday to attack the
Cathedral of Our Lady
so what Notre Dom means at the beginning
of Holy Week would have a lot of
significance even if it is just an
accident it certainly has a lot of
significance to Christians around the
world obviously to the people of France
and we'll keep you posted on that that
little bit of violence as for more
broadly speaking political violence in
the United States I guess I guess I'm
the story that today at least because
there was this event last Thursday at
the University of Missouri Kansas City
many of you watched it I was invited to
give a lecture there on the topic men
are not women pretty basic topic if you
took a time machine back to five years
ago and told people that that would be a
controversial topic in five years they
would laugh in your face so I go there
and I give this talk I try to give this
talk from the very beginning there was a
group of about a dozen leftists
screaming like banshees screaming so
loudly the other people in the room
could not hear it some of the people on
video could hear
because I was speaking directly into a
microphone that was being broadcast
people in the room couldn't because
these leftists screamed like hyenas for
consistently for about 20 minutes
eventually they get up and they go to
leave and they're screaming all these
crazy things at me and then from behind
me out of my periphery some leftist thug
wearing a face mask the bandana comes
and he squirts some unknown chemical at
me which had a very strong smell and it
had a weird color what he didn't realize
is that the police were right by that
door they dropped him to the ground in a
matter of seconds they arrested him very
quickly he was fighting back he did not
count on there being any consequences to
this so I went on I made some jokes
about it and tried to push on with the
speech it was first then reported that
it was paint that the guy tried to spray
on me that's kind of what I thought it
was then a lot of people in the room who
were closer to where the super soaker
full of this chemical was were reporting
that it was bleach so obviously it seems
like the authorities in the room thought
that this could be a dangerous chemical
which is why they responded so quickly
it later found out or we later found out
it was non-toxic household chemicals it
seems pretty clear that the kid this
this attacker was trying to give the
impression that it was some sort of
dangerous chemical but he wanted to
avoid multiple felonies on his record so
probably that was smart for him
regardless that the point of this is
pretty clear first of all could have
been anything that he was hurling on to
a conservative speaker and what it
really seems to be is a warning shot
which is that if you don't shut up if
you don't kowtow to leftist orthodoxy
you will be intimidated you'll be
shouted down and ultimately you'll be
physically attacked don't forget they
didn't start out trying to physically
attack me
they started out just trying to screen
me down and hoping that I would leave
and shut up when only when I didn't do
that did this guy bust in and try to
hurl some liquid on me that was the
ultimate point so we know that this kind
of violence has happened at universities
I'm not the first conservative speaker
to be attacked Charles Murray's been
attacked I think Christine off
was attacked this has happened at other
places the more shocking thing here was
the response the response of the
university the Chancellor of the
University of missouri-kansas city
Mali agrawal and the response of the
Kansas City Star and the mainstream
media more broadly what the left is
doing here is trying to equate violence
with non-violence that's the big
takeaway they've been doing it not just
to me in this story over the past three
days they've done it to president Trump
they've done it to Dan Crenshaw they're
trying to equate violence with
non-violence the university's reaction
next morning a letter comes out from the
chancellor's office I expect there to be
an apology to an invited speaker who was
harassed and then assaulted no no no
here's the letter from Chancellor Molly
Agrabah a student group brought a
speaker to campus a speaker whose
professed opinions do not align with our
commitment to diversity and inclusion
and our goal of providing a welcoming
environment to all people particularly
to our LGBT community first of all
what's my stated opinion the topic of
the speech is men are not women the
university doesn't agree with that the
university thinks men are women also the
irony they said this this doesn't speak
to our values of diversity I'm the only
one talking about diversity I'm saying
there's a diversity of sexes I'm saying
there's diversity between men and women
you're the ones saying that the sexes
are completely homogeneous there's no
such thing as women there's only one
sexes we're all the same there's no
difference between men and women but
more broadly this guy opens up his
letter not by condemning violence on
campus not by condemning the hecklers
veto in these banshee behaving students
who should be expelled from the
university no no no he opens up the
letter by baselessly smearing the
invited speaker as some sort of bigot he
said my opinions are
not welcoming to the LGBT community I'm
some sort of anti-gay bigot now does he
cite any of the opinions that are
apparently so bigoted no of course not
because he can't what could he say but
that's how he begins so so you can see
where the letter is gonna go from there
he says upon learning of this speakers
visit members of the UMKC community
responded in the best way by organizing
and conducting a counter event across
campus Thursday afternoon focused on
positive messages about diversity and
inclusion first of all that's not the
best way to respond the best way would
be to go and listen to the speaker and
then at a different time hold another
event where people who disagree with you
will go and then you will discuss these
differing ideas and people can come to
their own conclusions but to try to just
distract from the event and try to pull
people away from that that actually
isn't the best way to respond he goes on
even during the speech some peaceful
protesters stood and expressed
disagreement with the speaker's views
then unfortunately some others crossed a
line
no no what happened during the speech is
from the very moment that I started to
speak these activists shrieked so loudly
that nobody could hear the speech if a
university chancellor believes that that
is one of the best ways to respond then
he is a disgrace to higher education
molly agrawal is a disgrace to american
higher education to liberal education he
should resign he should be pressured by
the trustees and the alumni and the
governor and the students to resign that
is an outrage what he is saying in that
letter is that the best way to engage
with ideas that we might not understand
or that we might think that we disagree
with or that we maybe never have heard
before is to scream at the top of our
lungs like little children like toddlers
until they are cowered and intimidated
into leaving Mali Agrawal the Chancellor
of UMKC should resign or else the
trustee
is the alumni and the governor are
sending a message to every other college
in the country that it's perfectly fine
to shout down speakers and to shout down
views that are not trendy or faddish at
the time a lot more to get to
but first paid for by the National
Highway Traffic Safety Administration
Nitsa is working hard to combat texting
while driving
cops are writing tickets for people who
text while driving you drive you text
you pay thousands of people die every
year in crashes related to distracted
driving and cops are writing tickets for
people who text while driving texting
and driving isn't just a dangerous
problem it is deadly in fact thousands
of people die every year in crashes
related to distracted driving that's why
cops are out writing tickets to those
who text while driving and they're doing
it to save lives 20,000 people died
between 2012 and 2017 in crashes
involving a distracted driver think
about as stupid you would feel if you
died because you had to send some emoji
to your buddy
imagine how stupid you would feel and
imagine how much worse you would feel if
you caused harm to somebody else if you
god forbid killed somebody else because
you had to send one text don't do it if
you text while driving
you will get caught you drive you text
you pay it's not just dangerous it is
deadly when you drive while distracted
you're three times more likely to crash
far too many people still don't
recognize those dangers when you take
your eyes off the road to text for five
seconds at 55 miles an hour that is like
driving more than the length of a
football field with your eyes closed if
you text while driving you will get
caught you drive you text you pay so
this disgrace to higher education
MOLLE Agrawal goes on after defending
the hecklers veto after baselessly
smearing an invited speaker as some sort
of bigot he goes on imagine this imagine
the message this university is sending
out to say hey speakers we'd like you to
come to campus we'd like you to fly
across the country take time out of your
schedules to come here and give a speech
oh and by the way we're going to do
fend harassment and the hecklers veto
we're not really gonna condemn political
violence at least not primarily and
we'll get to that eventually maybe and
by the way we're gonna baselessly smear
you as a bigot but come on that's that's
what the university is for he goes on he
says UMKC must maintain a safe
environment in which all points of view
even extreme ones are allowed to be
heard I mentioned this one because in
2019 the opinion that men are not women
is an extreme point of view we hear a
lot as sort of moral equivalence between
the left and the right oh well you know
the left they do their crazy things on
the right they do their crazy things and
ah come on it's not no no no no the left
is saying eight a Chancellor of an
American University a state university
who is a left winger is saying that the
point of view that men are not women is
extreme and then the right is saying men
are not women those are not equally
extreme crazy viewpoints one of those is
radical and the other is common sense no
equivalence what so ever he says we
continue to urge everyone in our UMKC
community and the broader community to
stay true to our values in the face of
provocation provocation listen to these
words and to respond to bias and
intolerance with reason and courage to
hardened attitudes with open minds and
honest questions to false statements
with calm fact-based challenges listen
to what this disgrace does in this
letter he says that the students need to
respond to provocation in this way as
though I was begging to go visit UMKC I
was begging to fly across the country to
give the lecture please let me come
please I'll pay you let me come I was in
to the school your school Molly agrawal
the school that you represent invited me
to come
that's not provocation you provoked me
if anything provocation you invited me
to speak on a specific topic which I
then did and and for that grave mistake
that I apparently made taking Molly
Agrawal it is on face value for that for
that crazy mistake I was harassed and
physically assaulted and then smeared as
a bigot and then spirit smeared as a
provocateur and then smeared as an
extremist because I don't think men and
women are exactly the same bias and
intolerance that's how he describes men
are not women hardened attitude that's
how he describes a guy giving what is
actually basically a fairly boring
speech because it's on a very basic
topic that's the hardened attitude but
the lunatics shrieking and assaulting
people that's no that's open-minded
that's nice and a false statement men
are not women according to this disgrace
is a false statement
his reaction obviously ridiculous the
mainstream media's reaction even worse
even worse the Kansas City Star I didn't
realize how insanely left-wing this
newspaper is because you sometimes think
okay the main outlets NBC CBS the cable
outlets CNN MSNBC those are gonna be
really left-wing local news that they
don't have as much of a bias the Kansas
City Star is a more radical left-wing
outlet than any I have seen in the
country any mainstream this is how they
covered it they said quote protester
arrested during speakers
anti-transgender talk at UMKC
anti-transgender talk
apparently the statement men are not
women is now an anti transgender talk
ABC News had the same thing student
charged over protest at anti-transgender
speech so you see the picture they're
painting that
I'm some sort of hateful bigot who wants
to target people because of some
psychological issue they have
anti-transgender now of course none of
these can quote a single line from the
speech to back up their libel their
defamation their smears their dirt you
know why they can't do that because it's
not there so they have to make it up and
they have to insinuate and then they
move on eight the Associated Press did
the same thing anti transgender so they
set this up with this completely
baseless narrative of bigotry and then
then they move on to the next step which
is reversing the responsibility for the
attack so the Kansas City Star says
conservative commentator Michael Knowles
inflamed students when he spoke at
University of Missouri Kansas City on
April 11th so you see it's not that
leftist lunatics attacked a speaker who
was giving a speech he was invited to
give no no I have the active verb here i
inflamed the students it's got you seem
about the word flame in it that sounds
pretty dangerous they do this because
they need to equate speech with violence
they need to equate speech with violence
because they need to justify their
violence if I was just giving a talk on
a very common-sense topic and then some
guy assaults me well that doesn't look
very good for the left does it but if I
was inflaming students by saying that
men are not women well then it justifies
his violence this is the flipside of
this classic line we hear conservatives
pounced conservatives pounced
what did they pounce on what do they
seize on they put the responsibility on
me the Kansas City Star is saying then I
deserved it by the way we have a clip of
it here is here's what happened I was
trying to give the speech all a lot of
these students are walking out and then
all of a sudden this lunatic bumps in
and tries to squirt me with some
chemical
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay I'm laughing it near their reaction
at the end this masked lunatic comes in
with this squirt gun full of we didn't
know what chemical and shoots it at me
and then the cops thankfully take him
down and then they start yelling hands
up don't shoot not at the guy who shot
the thing out of the squirt gun
but at the cops who were taking him down
the masked assailant and they were using
a line that never happened in the first
place hands up don't shoot this was a
fiction pushed by the violent left to
gin up sentiment against cops who they
said wrongly shot Michael Brown it what
when was that 2015 total fiction did not
happen read the grand jury report but
that's the power of a narrative so you
see there is there any in flaming is
there any no no no this masked lunatic
busts in thankfully the cops take him
down you see it on the video there's
video of it everywhere okay then the KC
star goes on Kansas City star's his
protester at right wing UMKC event
arrested but was the speaker hoping for
a disruption young woman wearing a short
skirt was raped but was she asking for
it that's what they're saying that's
that is the exact logical progression
that the Kansas City Star is saying Mike
Fannin is the editor of the Kansas City
Star that's what he's saying hey Michael
your shirt was awful score your shirt
your skirt was awful short weren't you
asking for it weren't you hoping to be
as yeah you probably loved it
you probably loved having a masked
assailant come in and squirt you with an
unknown strange smelling weird colored
chemical you probably loved that huh
Mike Fannin
a City Star editor he said he starts out
quote an anti transgender speech
delivered at the University of Missouri
Kansas City was orchestrated by an
outside conservative group attempting to
cause disruption student leaders said
Friday now I was there I remember I got
the invitation and none of that is true
not only is none of that true it's all
demonstrably false one the speech was
not that derogatory toward any
transgender people it was not
orchestrated by an outside conservative
group we were invited by student
conservatives on campus they weren't
attempting to cause disruption we were
going to hold a private event where we
were lecturing on this topic that men
are not women we didn't tell the the
assailants that they had to come in and
shoot us with chemicals we didn't tell
people they had to come in and scream
like banshees the whole time but the
Kansas City Star says well some student
leaders said that and so huh that I mean
they said it so if they said it right I
mean it we don't care if it's true we're
not journalists we're propagandists for
the extreme left Mike Fannin Kansas City
Star this was an event to make us look
bad said justice Horne who is the first
black openly gay president of the UMKC
student body okay they used our platform
they used our name to bolster themselves
Horne said he believes a right-leaning
outside group targeted
UMKC is a place of diversity and
inclusion in an effort to polarize the
campus and make it appear intolerant we
made them appear we made it we made them
appear to be masked assailants shooting
chemicals that invited guests we made
them appear to be screaming hyenas who
cannot tolerate any lecture going on
that contradicts their orthodoxy so they
have to come show up to these other
peoples lecture and scream and shout the
whole time and we my guess we made them
do it it's probably selectively edited
video right and that right it's probably
it's probably deceptive right
it's on video you can see it but this is
what they do they can't take
responsibility for anything so they say
oh you made us you may disappear
intolerant you know we don't have to
make you appear intolerant you did just
fine all by yourself I said let this it
goes on Kansas City store Mike Fannin's
the editor about 20 minutes into
Knowles's speech laced with disparaging
comments about transgender people
audience members began to boo again that
isn't true the the heckling and the
harassing and the shouting and the
screaming started immediately also show
me one disparaging comment about a
transgender person in my speech show me
one comment Mike Fannin editor of the
Kansas City Star total hack none and
then so after all of that after they
tried to put the blame on student
conservatives who invited me to come
speak on the people who were just
peacefully trying to listen to the
lecture and on me who got squirted with
some unknown chemical after trying to
say that it was actually our fault
because we were asking for it because we
were wearing short skirts or something
after all that then they just try to
mock us so this is my favorite one
again Kansas City Star editorial board
Mike Fannin's the editor at UMKC a
delist conservative was sad to be
squirted with the makings of a bubble
bath you see because it was non-toxic
household chemicals so was the makings
of a bubble I was sad d-list
conservative by the way I've always
prided myself on being a c-list
conservative
all right I've worked very hard in my
life to be a c-list conservative call me
a d-list conservative deal is
conservative first of all by the way
apparently I'm a prominent enough
conservative for the Kansas City Star to
write three separate editorials and
op-eds in one day trying to divide
campus conservatives trying to smear us
as bigots and also publishing obvious
untruths I wonder if there's any legal
consequence to publishing untruths about
people that are defamatory I don't know
I wonder I don't got to worry about that
he goes on Knowles couldn't wait to
claim victimhood this is a tiny tip for
tiny tad it's
so the mutual troller ii referred to as
the debate over free speech on campus
there's no mutual troller ii a
conservative was giving a speech at a
university leftists attacked that
speaker that's not a tit-for-tat that's
not a tit-for-tat you hax but this is
what they do this is it's not just about
me we'll get to it's not even just about
the other speakers who get attacked on
campuses this goes all the way up to
Congress this goes all the way up to the
White House this is what the left has
been doing for 50 years and and we are
now seeing the fruit of their ideology
which conflate speech with violence
we'll get to in a second but first got
to go to daily wire.com
if you want to watch the rest 10 bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership you
get me at the end reclaim and show you
get the Ben Shapiro show you get the
mount wall show you can test questions
in the mailbag coming up on Thursday you
get to ask questions backstage you get
the leftist here's tumblr this is very
important apparently if you're ever
passing through Kansas City you're gonna
want to have your leftist here's tumblr
with you this is very very important
stuff I figured state of Missouri you
know pretty normal state apparently not
apparently there are a lot of leftist
lunatics there you got to make sure you
have your left is tears tumblr we'll be
right back with a lot more
so the left conflates speech with
violence we see this in the language
they use they talk about safe spaces we
need safe spaces now it's not safe from
physical violence you know actual
violence no no safe spaces are safe from
opinions that certain people don't like
realities that certain people don't like
but you need safe not just oh I don't
know intellectually homogeneous spaces
not just politically correct spaces no
safe spaces because the implication here
is that if you have an opinion that is
not in line with trends or fads or
leftist orthodoxy then you are actually
committing violence and this brings us
to probably the biggest national story
right now which is the sad case of Ilan
Omar Ilan Omar is a terrible person Ilan
Omar regularly defends terrorists
terrorist organizations and she
downplays terrorist actions some people
have criticized her for this like the
president like congressman dan Crenshaw
a great guy like me like other people
they've criticized her for defending
terrorists defending terrorist
organizations and downplaying terrorist
attacks and now the left is trying to
say that that very criticism is violence
that that very criticism is inciting
violence they're saying that if you
don't even criticize her but you just
show alon omar using her own words that
that is inciting violence if you show
this video according to the left you're
inciting violence here was founded after
9/11 because they recognize that some
people did something and that all of us
were starting to lose access to our
civil liberties
911 3000 American civilians killed Alon
Omar member of Congress says that some
people did something if you show this
video of Alon Omar you are now according
to the left inciting violence against
Ilana more every time the the professor
said okay that he sort of like his
shoulders went up and you know commanded
a al Qaeda and it was you know as you
probably get to see him on CNN
yeah of course I love those guys you
know but but but it is it is that you
don't say America with an intensity you
don't say England with the intensity you
know you don't you don't say the army
with an intensity car though but you say
these these names because you you want
that that word to carry weight so not
only does Ilana more say the words
Hezbollah and al-qaeda with giddiness
laughing he has bola al-qaeda but then
lest you think she's being taken out of
context she makes her point very clear
she says you don't say America and
England and the army the same way that
you say Hezbollah and al-qaeda right
because Hezbollah and al-qaeda are
terrorist organizations and America is
the greatest country in the history of
the world which comes from England
another one of the greatest countries in
the history of the world it's protected
by the army which protects the greatest
country in the history of the world
what Elon omar is saying is America
England the army al Qaeda Hamas they're
all basically kind of the same thing
that's why it's so strange that you say
them differently well we all say them
differently than she does because she's
giddy when she says al Qaeda and Hamas
she's laughing now according to the left
to point that out too
Oh a video of her speaking is inciting
violence against Ilan Omar sounds like
Elon Omar's inciting violence against
herself but actually she's not even
doing that
she's just voicing an opinion a terrible
opinion an awful opinion but that speech
is not violence even her saying those
awful things is not inciting violence
against herself now President Trump and
Dan Crenshaw and I and like everybody
else on the right everybody every
right-thinking person every
right-thinking Democrat a dwindling
group of people but there are still some
of them have roundly condemned her for
these remarks and others and now we're
being told that this is inciting
violence by none other than lieth or
herself Elizabeth Warren Senate Rick's
20/20 Democrat candidate here she is
saying Donald Trump by by showing a
video of you on Omar is inciting
violence obviously thank you for sending
out a tweet so quickly last night
defending congressman Omar and calling
out Donald Trump's bigotry towards her
which as you put it was inciting
violence and it's scary for me what
moved you to get involved so quickly on
that because that's what it is he's
trying to incite violence he's trying to
divide us as a country that's a
dangerous dangerous path to go down and
not not who we want to be as a nation
that's a dangerous dangerous path to go
down you see what Donald Trump's doing
Donald Trump's words or putting us on a
dangerous dangerous path do you see what
she just did I don't think she realized
what she just did by her argument if
criticism is inciting violence then
Elizabeth Warren just incited violence
against Donald Trump and I guess I'm
criticizing Elizabeth Warren so I guess
I incited violence against Elizabeth
Warren and if one of you out there
listening or watching doesn't agree with
something that I've said I guess you're
inciting violence against me I went and
I saw the latest Star Wars movie
and it was very bad I guess I'm inciting
violence against the Star Wars movie
right I went to a restaurant the other
night or in a nice plate of bucatini I I
had it the pasta was overcooked
I guess I'm inciting violence against
the chef or a knight no of course not
criticism is not inciting violence but
by the way what Elizabeth Warren's
saying is far more incendiary than what
Donald Trump said about Ilan Omar what
do you wanna what Donald Trump did was
he posted a video of Ilan Omar saying
that 9/11 was just some people doing
some thing and he said we will never
forget never forget the 3,000 people who
were killed in 9/11 what Liz Warren said
is that Donald Trump's putting us on a
dangerous path which of those is more
incendiary which of those is more likely
to incite violence
moreover mark dice put together a great
little run-through of left-wingers on
television who apparently were not as
concerned about inciting violence a year
or two years ago might need to check
their privilege and 25% in the country
whether it's 25 20 30 % are hardcore
racist they do not want to see brown
people coming into America that's that's
just what's going on here if you vote
for Trump then you the voter you not
Donald Trump or standing at the BART
border like Nazis go you hear you hear
and I think we now have to flip it and
it's a given the evilness of Donald
Trump are they just the most stoic human
beings are they numb are they dead
inside votes for and supports a racist
is a racist you are culpable white
America I'm sorry if you hold down the
woman while the rapist is raping her and
you didn't rape her are you a rapist now
that's just harsh criticism so obviously
it seems by the left standard that's an
incitement to violence that is violence
but when you listen to it it's really
just harsh criticism you're a racist
your equivalent to a rapist
yeah you're like this you're like this
you're like this it's all criticism but
actually the left doesn't even stop
there the left out right threatens
violence all the time
here's just a quick quick little rundown
like we could go on for 10 hours about
it just a quick little rundown of
leftists actually calling for violence
yes I have thought an awful lot about
blowing up the white house new details
today on the incident that left Senator
Rand Paul with six broken ribs this
might be one of my favorite stories
although of course we don't want a
clearly senator Paul's still struggling
president Walker how do you is this the
temptation to run up and wring her neck
you cannot be civil a political party
that wants to destroy what you stand for
what you care about that's why I believe
if we are fortunate enough to win back
the house and/or the Senate
that's when civility can start again
when was the last time an actor
assassinated a president but it was the
last time an actor assassinated a
president those are major left-wing
donors major left-wing celebrity
spokesman at major left-wing politicians
Maxine Waters and Hillary Clinton major
left-wing media figures KC hunt was that
I think on MSNBC one of those left-wing
people one of those left-wing mainstream
media Talking Heads the left is more
violent than the right there is some
violence among right-wingers there is
much much much more violence on the left
and so what the left must do is equate
speech with violence because there are a
lot more logical arguments coming out of
the right there's a lot more civil
discussion coming out of the right and
so if the if the tools that are being
used here to fight this cultural battle
are on the right generally speaking
arguments and on the left generally
speaking hysterics and threats and acts
of violence then the only way that the
left can possibly win in the court of
public opinion is to equate speech with
violence so that's what they have to do
that's what they're trying to do
it's what the Kansas City Star is doing
that's what Chancellor Molly agrawal at
the University of Missouri Kansas City
is doing he's doing it more subtly he's
doing it more tacitly but he's doing it
nevertheless that's what the people
defending Alana Omar are doing
mainstream media elected Democrats I got
to tell you how long have I been
involved in politics how long have we
been doing this show I have no illusions
about the integrity of the mainstream
media but there's really something that
happens when they do in a hit job on you
personally where you just see the lies
you can identify the lies word by word
sentence by sentence and you say these
guys are totally corrupt these guys are
total not only is there ID ideology
corrupt and crooked but their actions
are - that's what's happening here
and you have to defend the right to
criticize if we don't have the right to
criticize we don't have a republic the
Senate is known as the greatest
deliberative body in the world I know
this is kind of an ironic name these
days but that's what it's supposed to be
our republic or ability to govern
ourselves is based on the idea that we
can criticize each other we can
criticize ideas and we can do it in a
way that doesn't burn the whole country
to the ground that doesn't spark
violence and the left is increasingly
incapable of certainly of accepting any
criticism but even if engaging in any
ideas
self-government is difficult it requires
maturity it requires intellect it
requires education and as we see on
display all throughout the mainstream
media as we see on display all the way
at the nation's capital and certainly as
we saw on display at the University of
Missouri Kansas City all of those things
are in short supply and shortening
supply look to the University as that's
the future of the country
that's the next generation doesn't paint
a very pretty picture just one note I'll
leave you on from this mainstream media
cycle there was a story in Reuters
headline said man arrested after boy
falls from balcony of Minnesota's Mall
of America boy falls from balcony man
arrested what really happened Reuters
tells us in the first paragraph a
five-year-old boy suffered
life-threatening injuries on Friday
after being thrown or pushed by an
apparent stranger from a third-floor
balcony at Minnesota's Mall of America
man who fled the scene has been charged
with attempted homicide police said
shortly after the incident police
arrested a 24 year-old man inside the
mall one of the state's leading tourist
attractions after he'd fled the scene
the suspect Emanuel Deshawn Rhonda who
is from the area was charged with
attempted homicide so what happened is a
guy pushed a kid off a balcony and
nearly killed him and may have killed
him we don't know he's a parent a very
bad shape and what his Reuters report
man arrested after boy falls from
balcony now why did they report this way
if I had to guess something tells me
that the race of the of the victim and
the perpetrator played some role the man
who pushed the boy allegedly is a black
guy and the boy apparently is a white
kid and this is a narrative this is a
racial narrative that Reuters can cannot
permit and so you hear this kind of
ridiculous language man arrested after
boy falls from balcony in Minnesota's
Mall of America what happened what would
happen of course if it were imagine if
the if the Vick
were a an ethnic minority child and a
white guy was the one who pushed him
could you imagine imagine if it were a
cop who when we know what happens when
cops have in the line of duty injured or
killed the ethnic minority children or
teenagers or even adults we know we know
how that narrative is pushed by the
mainstream media but something like this
it just shows you how much spin how much
narrative there really is and it gets so
nasty why does it get so nasty because
in the 1960s the left insisted on a new
line a new premise the personal is the
political the personal is the political
previously the political was the
political the personal was the personal
your public life was something that was
different than your private life the
nation's public life was something
different than the private life in the
1960s they said now everything is about
to get really really personal and so it
becomes nasty it becomes person it
becomes not about ideas not about
elevated modes of behavior it becomes
about personal pushing narratives
spinning out writeline when you have to
you got to be on alert you've got to be
paying attention if you didn't know it
before you cannot trust anything you
read in the mainstream media I wish that
weren't the case but it is that's where
we are that's where the left is and we
cannot allow ourselves to be bullied and
we have to fight back and we are people
asked me if I was going to cancel the
rest of my speaking tour no way the tour
just got ten schools longer I'm going
tomorrow night to Texas A&M with drew
Clavin we're gonna have a good time down
there and then I'm gonna be at Cal State
Los Angeles next Tuesday but I'll see
you before then tomorrow in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt oh I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 hey guys over
on the Matt Walsh show today well the
Democrat says I'm sure you've been
seeing that there they're claiming that
you know conservatives incite violence
against Ilhan Omar by criticizing her
and her reprehensible comments that she
made about 9/11 well this is just a
dishonest deceitful ploy and it's all
about shutting down free speech that's
all it's really about we're going to
talk about it also on a positive side I
want to talk about one great thing about
America that I think is embodied by the
reaction to Tiger Woods's big masters
win yesterday and finally I got a one of
the most disturbing pieces of hate mail
I think I've ever received and this is
from a deranged dog lover who's upset
because I criticized dogs and I don't
know I just want to share it with you
because it's it's it's something else
well do all that today over on the Matt
Walsh Oh